have you seen of a tick-tock go viral
about a fan wanting you to play zelda in
a live-action movie based on what you
wore to the vanity fair party no i know
not they were like cast her right away
yeah is that something you'd be
interested or a role you would like to
pursue i mean yeah that would be cool
like an elf yeah and i mean i played
that video game a bunch when i was a kid
that's such a good game um yeah that's
cool i'm just saying i see it i see
zelda i see it
it's so exciting to see you guys all
together i know you guys filmed season
two so long ago so does it feel like a
nice little reunion uh yeah yeah i mean
the last time everyone was together was
like our little mini premiere which was
actually much smaller than this so we
were here yeah yeah was not expecting a
thing of this uh size which is really
cool also yeah we're at the academy
which is crazy i've never been here
before the academy museum very cool what
would it mean to get some love from the
tv academy for this second season
obviously you know zendaya made history
that first one but what do we what would
it mean to get that nomination for the
show i mean uh i just uh think i i mean
awards are not like
the show i'm i'm really proud of it i
think it's really special um but uh i
think in like in terms of
um you know wanting to keep doing it and
making a really good
next season uh awards are sort of a good
affirmation not only for us but for like
the studio that we're doing something
right and uh and that uh it's being
received well not only by the people who
are making it but uh by the people who
are consuming it you know you got to
co-write and co-produce a special
episode in that first season is that
something you would want to revisit for
the third i mean absolutely i mean uh
you know that was a it was a special
circumstance and that they were
independent episodes and uh um and it
was in covet and everything uh
and sam has a very particular way of
working so i'm not sure if that exact
sort of format would ever
happen in quite the same way again but
um i mean i i was just saying over there
like i feel like i'm always learning um
on the set just uh there's everyone's
working so hard and is so skilled at
making like one big beautiful thing and
uh and so even when i'm not you know a
producer i still feel like absorbing
absorbing a lot which is magical yeah
[Music]
you